today on the matt wall show a video of a
white man being beaten with a brick in
baltimore is uploaded to instagram with
the caption
white lives matter this is the latest
apparently racially motivated assault on
a white person
the media of course is ignoring it but
it's happening and the reason why it's
happening is clear we'll talk about that
today also five headlines including uh
trump
getting in trouble for speaking truth
about blm and joe biden having a mental
breakdown on live tv you have to see it
you really have to see the tape and in
our daily cancellation i will cancel
everyone who is currently trying to
cancel adele for her
supposedly racist hairstyle how can a
hairstyle be racist we'll find that out
today all of that and much more on the
way we begin with this
the city of baltimore lived up to its
reputation yet again this weekend
when a white man was beaten over the
head with a brick as he walked down the
street it was all caught on film
by another person who appeared to know
that the attack was about to happen
and laughed uh when the victim was sent
crashing to the pavement with a gash in
his skull
footage was posted to instagram with the
caption white lives do not matter
as of now the condition of the victim is
not known last i saw
police arrived on the scene later to
find only a pool of blood on the
sidewalk
now that i've described it to you i'll
play the video for you because no
description can quite capture
these sorts of things so watch and
listen to the reaction of the people
filming
now think about the mindset you must
have to actually think that bludgeoning
a random guy as he walks down the street
is funny
we're talking about violent sociopathy
at the level of serial killers
okay not that the people filming the
attack or the attacker himself
are serial killers just that morally and
psychologically
they're on that level they take actual
joy in witnessing brutality against the
innocent
now as far as white people being
brutalized though this is not an
isolated occurrence it was only
two weeks ago that a white man was
beaten unconscious by a black lives
matter protester in
portland last week a man in colorado
yelled black lives matter before
stabbing a white man in the lungs
that same week a man in georgia walked
into an auto parts store and knifed a
white employee
later confessing that he felt the need
to find a white male to kill
again in the same week an elderly white
man was knocked apparently unconscious
after trying to stop looters from
ransacking his business this assault was
met with approval
by um activist tariq nasheed who
baselessly labeled the victim a
suspected white supremacist
and celebrated his attackers as quote
freedom fighters
now these can all be added to the
growing list of assaults on
white people over the last few months
which includes the white female beaten
with wooden boards by a group of black
men
during the riots and uh the 92 year old
white lady casually pushed to the ground
by a black man as he walked past she hit
her head on a fire hydrant
and these are only the physical assaults
we're talking about we haven't accounted
for the black lives matter demonstrators
screaming at white diners in dc
or blm activists elsewhere in the
country engaging in all manner of
harassment
and intimidation often explicitly aimed
at
whites now we'll be assured that these
cases are not
numerous enough to count as a trend or
an epidemic but
i note that almost everyone who would
make that dismissive argument
argument about black on white violence
will in the next breath
insist that random videos of police
officers shooting black men
do count as both a trend and an epidemic
and we could be quite certain that if in
the span of seven days a black man was
kicked in the head and knocked
unconscious by a white supremacist
and then there were two separate
stabbing attacks carried out by white
men screaming white lives
matter these same people
would call you a racist in league with
nazis if you didn't conclude that black
people are being hunted in the street
all across the country indeed we're
already told that black people are quote
unquote literally hunted to use
lebron james phrase by by white people
even though the crime statistics clearly
show that a black person is more likely
to kill a white person than a white
person a black person that's what the
stats show
now whether you think these cases listed
at the top
equate to a trend or just an unfortunate
series of oddly similar events
the main point is that they're not
happening in a vacuum
okay when a group of people are cast as
the villain
and labeled an existential threat to
other groups
and then members of that villain group
wind up dead or
beaten in quote-unquote random attacks
or accosted by angry mobs
it is simply ludicrous to deny the
obvious connection
in our culture it is dogma that whites
are all inherently racist
that they are privileged and have earned
that privilege by stealing from other
races note the
blm activists demanding that whites give
up their homes and the blm leader in
chicago announcing that blacks can loot
all they want because
um they're only taking what they're owed
um that's dogma it's dogma that they
enter that
white people enter the police force so
that they can stalk and murder black
people for sport
it's dogma that um white people should
be ashamed of their past and their
ancestral
heritage that the only thing they ought
to feel about being white
is guilt this is a rough summary of
critical race theory it's been force-fed
to college students for decades preached
from every pulpit
pulpit that the left has available to it
to include many church pulpits by the
way
now if you're a non-white person and you
take
all of this and you listen to it and you
take it seriously
and you especially notice that it's now
considered normal and healthy to express
racial resentments through violent
outbursts under the guise of protest
then what else are you gonna do
believing that whites are racist by
their nature and that everything they've
done
everything that they have has been in
some sense earned unjustly or stolen
why wouldn't you attack and rob them and
if they're quote unquote hunting you
or are in league with those who hunt you
then beating them senseless
is practically an act of self-defense
it's what they deserve at least
what they would have done to you it's
not that
every non-white person buys this
narrative obviously most don't and most
aren't doing these sorts of things but
when a message like this is being
broadcast from every corner of the
culture
and powerful forces are working every
day to advance this narrative
and brainwash people especially young
people into it
it's simply inevitable that it will
persuade some
and then there will be others who are
not necessarily persuaded but are happy
to use the excuse given to them to act
out violently you know the rioters
aren't necessarily angry at anybody
i doubt that most of them are sincerely
convinced of the rightness
of their cause as they burn and loot and
steal they do it for fun
and because it's a it's an opportunity
to get a new pair of shoes and a tv
and the narrative gives them the excuse
they need this includes of course
other white people who consider
themselves to be the good ones
and thus they have an excuse as well to
assault and burn and destroy
now keep in mind
that some of the people who committed
some of the acts mentioned earlier
are probably mentally ill the guy who
stabbed the white man and shot at black
lives matter
well he waited for police to show up and
then told them that
he's quote i just stabbed someone i'm a
psychopath
now generally if a man stabs another man
and identifies himself as a psychopath
he probably is but that only proves my
point all the more
there are all kinds of people out there
who for one reason or another
will be susceptible to this villain
narrative about a whole race of people
when when they take the narrative to
heart and act on it
the fault lies with lies without a doubt
at least in part
with those advancing that narrative
now if you want to know how bad it's
gotten
then consider not any example of
violence already listed but consider the
simple fact that as i speak right now
and talk about this subject many in the
audience are wincing
not because they disagree but because
they're uncomfortable with this subject
being discussed at all
that's where we are now to simply make
the statement
that white people are being assaulted
and killed which is obviously true
and that this is bad which is obviously
true also
and that we're in an environment where
there's a hyper focus on the real or
imagined sins of white people
and that all of this must be logically
connected in some way which is again
all obviously true to make all of these
obviously true observations is
provocative
and controversial that alone tells you
what you need to know i mean i was
accused of race baiting because i posted
that video of the
of the white guy being beaten with a
brick are we not supposed to even talk
about it
it's race-baiting to even bring up that
a white guy was just bludging with a
brick while he was walking down the
street
the point here is that claims of there
being some sort of systemic conspiracy
among white people to discriminate
against and kill black people claims
that you know white cops are
white supremacist murderers claims that
white people living in the year 2020 owe
restitution for
sins committed by white people a century
and a half ago all of these claims
these are not mere virtue signals these
are not mere talking points
these are especially at this point as
america descends
every day further into anarchy and
violence these are incitements
these are calls to violence these are
cover for violent mobs
the rich and powerful people who tell
these fables they know what they're
doing
and they sit in comfort confident that
the violence will never come to their
doorstep until one day it does
because a fire if it gets enough fuel
can no longer be controlled
let's get to five headlines
[Music]
you know one of the worst things about
having car trouble where
there's nothing good about it so it's
all bad but one of the worst things is
you know you take the car
to the mechanic and you're just waiting
you're waiting for that phone call to
find out
how much it's going to be and it's
always it's always worse than you
imagined it was going to be that's the
way it works and these days computer
systems and cars you know the new normal
from electronically controlled
transmissions to touch screen displays
to dozens of sensors
the problem is that you can't fix any of
these new features yourself
okay so when something breaks it could
cost a fortune and now is not the time
especially for expensive repairs
that's why i have car shield car shield
has affordable protection plans that can
save you thousands for a covered repair
including computers gps electronics and
more
the people at car shield understand
payment flexibility is an absolute must
particularly uh you know in recent times
so monthly plans can be customized
to your needs with rates as low as 99 a
month no long-term contracts or
commitments car shield
gives you options that others won't you
get to choose your favorite mechanic or
dealership
uh to do the work car shield takes care
of all the rest so it
makes it simpler for you and um and a
whole hell of a lot cheaper
uh this is this is just it and you know
what else it takes away
takes away the anxiety as well of you
don't have to worry you know that
you know whatever whatever the cost is
you've got car shield you've got it
covered
that's how i feel about having car
shields it's great so for as low as 99
a month you can protect yourself from
surprises and you can save
thousands of dollars for a covered
repair call 800 car
6000 that's uh 800 car
6000 and start saving today
okay um well here we go again protests
in la last night more protests this one
started with blm
los angeles sending out this tweet here
it says los angeles county sheriff's
killed a black man dejean
on 109th and bud long and left his body
face down in the dirt
we need all hands on deck please get
here asap
notice how there's no information about
the circumstances of the shooting
just that somebody was shot that's
because it doesn't matter they don't
care if police kill a black man for any
reason
literally any reason now they will riot
that's the way this is going and so it
doesn't matter
uh what the circumstances are but as far
as they go um
just just uh just you know for the
record
as far as we know them anyway right now
the suspect got into a fight with cops
punched the cops had a gun at one point
produced the handgun
and uh and then was shot still plenty of
unknown details here
but based on what we know there's of
course no reason to be protesting
if there is a reason then we don't have
that information yet
armed man physically assaults cops okay
that's the headline so far
um and if if that's what happened then
guess whose fault it is when the armed
man assaulting the cops
gets hurt or killed oh you know by the
way the cop who pulled the trigger
appears to be hispanic
on top of it although we're told white
hispanic
you know so we're doing that trick again
there's a he's hispanic but he's white
hispanic so we can still make this about
white suprema
white supremacy once again though you
see how all agency and willpower is
removed from the suspects in these
police shootings
it's the way it always goes you know
they assault cops draw weapons etc
and we act like they played no role at
all in their own death
like they couldn't have been expected to
not do that
but the thing is you know this is not a
coincidence that almost everyone in
america
white black any other race who doesn't
assault cops
and use weapons on them manages to not
get shot by
the police crazy coincidence right i
don't think it is
like there's a there's a real connection
here
i succeed in not assaulting cops every
day of my life i
it's it's you know i i just did it again
yes yesterday i went through a whole day
didn't assault any police officers
and i also was not shot by any police
officers i really think there might be
a connection i got pulled over recently
and through the whole interaction i
actually did not at any point
punch the police officer i did get a
ticket
but the other thing is if if i had
decided to punch the police officer
there are basically two you know
what would have been a ticket now it's
going to be different i'll still get the
ticket
but uh if i'm still alive but
when i start that assault of the police
officer there's really only two
directions that can go
one is me to prison um dealing with a
much worse charge or or infraction than
what it would have been otherwise
or dead you know or in the hospital
paralyzed i mean
those are really the only it's like once
you start doing that
there's there's no good result for you
at all
i mean there might be good results for
the hacks and race-baiters and
charlatans out there
who want to use your death or your
maiming your injury
uh to advance their own narrative and to
sow you know more
uh division and everything so for them
sure but for you no
this is like a really basic message that
somehow gets lost
we forget to mention it
okay let's go um number two here's
another thing
you wouldn't expect but big surprise
here people are upset about something
that trump said
they are i know really surprising uh so
let's take a
let's listen to this he was on he was in
on laura ingram last night and uh
then he you know used he was talking and
everything that he said was horribly
offensive
this part right here was super offensive
and upsetting though listen to this
black lives matter is a marxist
organization
you remember pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon that was the first time i
ever heard of black lives matter
i said that's a terrible name it's so
discriminatory it's bad for black people
it's bad for everybody
and all of a sudden it becomes like sort
of although now if you look it's going
way down because people are tired of
this stuff what's going on
the black lives matter if you look at
what's going on with the bats and the
a lot of thugs running through dc last
night oh it's terrible what's going on
my god how dare you trump how dare you
say these things
that are incontrovertibly and obviously
correct yes black lives matter is a
marxist organization
their founders have said so publicly why
are we still pretending that this is
some sort of offensive they've said it
listen to them they're the ones who's i
we didn't say it
it's not our fault i'd prefer black
lives matter was not in a marxist
organization
but it is and that's what their own
founders have said
so there you go um now now that we've
checked in with trump let's see what uh
biden is up to covet has taken this year
just since the outbreak has taken more
than
100 years look here's the lives
it's just it's when you think about it
more lives this year than any other year
for the past
hundred years okay i have a transcript
here um
if you didn't follow that the transcript
is covid has taken this year just since
the outbreak it's taken more than a
hundred years
look here's the lives it's just it's
just think about it more lives this year
than any other year for the past 100
years
i'm not trying to be funny i really have
no idea what he's even trying to say
there i can't decipher it
this isn't one of those times where
somebody stumbles or has a gaff
and you kind of know what they were
trying to say but you pretend that you
don't just
just to try to just to uh you know just
to dig the um
dig the knife in deeper but no this is
not that i really don't even know what
he was going for it's taken more lives
than at any other point in the last 100
years is that what he's trying to say
covet 19 is a new thing it hasn't been
around so
i don't know what that means and just so
you know what you saw there
you know um because it's tempting when
you see these kinds of things with biden
to say well look he had a brain fart
you know he stumbled over his words
everybody does it um
yeah everyone does i mean i've had many
brain farts in my day
i have a particularly flatulent brain in
that way and
i stumble over my words all the time but
something like that
that's not normal that is just not
normal
to complete in the middle of a sentence
you completely
lose everything you are going to say
and it's especially not normal when it
happens all the time like it does with
joe biden
uh number four jk rowling still
suffering the consequences of publicly
acknowledging that biology exists has
now
given back her robert f kennedy ripple
of hope human rights award
which is good because now they have an
extra one lying around so now i can
finally
win it you know um but she gave it back
after the president of the organization
carrie kennedy came out
and attacked rowling for believing that
men can't get pregnant very you know
obviously very offensive
thing to believe and uh so i'm reading
now from forbes it says kerry kennedy
published
a statement this month to the rfk human
rights website
displaying multiple statements made by
rowling in recent months
and saying um
on and and okay this is what she said no
i'm losing track of what i said no i'm
pulling a button
uh so this is this is kerry kennedy she
says i have spoken with jk rowling to
express my profound disappointment
that she has chosen to use her
remarkable gifts to create a narrative
that diminishes the identity of trans
and non-binary people
undermining the validity and integrity
of the entire transgender community
trans rights are human rights j.k
rowling's attacks upon the transgender
community are inconsistent with the
fundamental beliefs and values of rfk
human rights
and represent a repudiation of my
father's vision
um okay
can i just say if someone's opinion
somehow undermines the validity and
integrity of your very
existence then you might have issues
that go way beyond
that opinion i in my life
have never felt that the validity of my
existence was undermined by anyone's
words or thoughts
and i've been insulted many times i
assure you
i i have many very horrible things have
been said to me
um i would wager in fact that i have
heard more horrible things said to me
and about my family than
the average transgender person has heard
in their life i i think i can feel
pretty
confident in that um
but in in any case and sometimes it
takes me off it's annoying
i don't like it i've never felt that the
validity of my existence was undermined
i don't even know what that means
i exist i'm sure of that
i don't need the i don't need my
validity or the integrity of my
existence to be affirmed by anyone so
this constant need for affirmation this
panic
um that you see you know from lgbt
activists folks
the way they panic if anywhere set if
anywhere if anyone anywhere says
anything that lgbt activists
don't like um the fact that they always
need everyone all the time to validate
them
and will try to destroy anyone who fails
to provide that validation
that might speak to some deeper things
going on
i don't know just a thought you know if
you feel like you need your existence
your very existence and what was it she
said the integrity
the integrity of the entire community
if you feel like you need your existence
to be validated and the integrity of
your
community validated whatever that means
then again i would say maybe there's
some deeper things going on
okay five finally for our most important
story of the day residents of an alabama
town are being terrorized
by a goat who eats
their mail this harrowing footage was
uploaded to facebook
you take a look at it here there's the
goat
there he is that bastard look at him
that's a federal crime by the way
this is not a joke there could have been
a coupon for 10 percent off a new
mattress in there
now that's gone it's that's he's
stealing money that's money out the
window
let me tell you there's a reason that
goats have always been considered
satanic
they eat your mail they have weird
looking eyes
they they do other
things i mean you may be wondering why i
take the goat issue so seriously
and you may wonder why i'm still talking
about it right now
and you may be thinking matt the goat
joke is over move on
well i'll tell you why because my wife
has been recruiting my children my
children my own flesh and blood
has been recruiting them and together
they have been waging a pressure
campaign against me for months now to
get me to consent to buying a goat
this is a serious thing now in my family
they want a goat i don't know why
the other day my my daughter came into
the living room started talking about
the goat oh daddy can we get a go
i see my wife behind the door like
feeding her lines
okay it's a conspiracy
but i'm not gonna have this mailbox
tampering scumbag anywhere near my home
that's all i'm saying
so goats are canceled uh that was a
precancellation before we get to the
main cancellation of the day which we
will do
in just a second but before we do that i
want to tell you about
omaha steaks uh look my family has loved
omaha steaks for
a long time now and the great thing
about steaks is you know the product
that they send to you
it's so good that it can make even if
you're not a great cook i mean i happen
to be a brilliant cook but if you're not
it can even make you seem like a
brilliant cook just because
the meat is that delicious right now
omaha steaks is offering a steakhouse a
grilling package with an exclusive offer
just for my listeners go to
omahasteaks.com
enter a code walsh into the search bar
and this week
omaha steaks will add four burgers and
four gourmet
jumbo franks free with your order okay
to reiterate uh four free burgers and
four
franks and by the way i've had their
burgers uh they're absolutely delicious
it's called the grand
summer grill out package and it lets you
stay at home
and eat like you're at the best steak
house in town we're talking oma steaks
bacon wrapped filet mignon plus pork
chops chicken
much more all of that delivered to your
door and it makes it it makes it
exciting make sure the goat isn't out
there okay that's another thing gotta be
careful there's no goats in the city
that's one thing they'll definitely
steal
smoky sweet bacon fork tendered filet
mignon
all for much less than going out to a
restaurant visit omahastakes.com type
walsh
in their search bar to get this today
again go to omahastakes.com
type walsh in the search bar and get
this deal today
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation today for our daily
cancellation i will be canceling all of
the cancellers of the british pop star
uh adele adele is the latest white
celebrity to get herself into trouble
for the imaginary sin of cultural
appropriation
now the singer posted a picture of
herself sporting bantu knots which is a
traditional african hairstyle
featuring multiple buns or knots adele
has
presumably worn many hairstyles over the
years all of those styles have origins
somewhere it's doubtful that any of them
originate in modern britain
is she supposed to check an encyclopedia
every time she wants to put her hair up
to ensure that she doesn't fashion it in
a way that bears similarity to
hairstyles worn by non-white people
apparently so racial justice demands it
it's really not so much to ask when you
think about it
so as as cities burn in our country
deals with multiple major crises at once
our friends on the left you know still
had time to worry about the way a woman
across the ocean decided to fashion her
hair
ernest owens a self-described
award-winning journalist and rich guy on
the forbes list
spoke out valiantly on this important
issue he said if 2020 couldn't get any
more bizarre adele is giving us
bantu knots and cultural appropriation
that nobody asked for
this officially marks all of the top
women and pop as problematic
now owens an alleged grown man is
himself appropriating
from 19 year old pink hair gender
studies majors by calling an utterly
innocuous thing
problematic also i didn't realize that
people had to
ask for a certain hairstyle before we're
allowed to wear it
like who who who should we ask before we
wear
are we supposed to be asking ernest
owens every morning as you comb your
hair just shoot a quick message to owens
explain what style you're thinking of
going with for the day and you know wait
for him to give you the go-ahead i mean
he has to ask you to wear it before
you're allowed to wear it other
luminaries like jameel hill last seen
while claiming that the united states is
analogous to nazi germany you might
remember that from last week
um also swooped in to deliver a scolding
to a woman who
wore too many buns in her hair i mean i
assume that is the problem here it's too
many buns not the bun
itself because ancient greeks wore buns
yes i actually did look this up um
i mean it's safe to assume even that you
know many people in ancient times
probably wore
hairstyles that included multiple buns
so the age-old question
how many buns can adele have before she
becomes racist what is the
bun threshold now i counted nine visible
buns yes i did count
would she be racist with just five buns
what about six
and by the way are we certain that the
nine or ten bun style originates with
african women
i mean do we know that no other culture
anywhere on earth ever thought of doing
that many buns
these are questions that the
appropriation police never answer
can't answer left-wing bloggers also
left into action uh
thankfully a writer for the website the
root wrote a lengthy article on the
issue of adele's hair
and she lamented that the singer you
know would do something so callous as to
put her hair in a bun
when adele has been says the writer up
to this point
among the least problematic faves of the
caucasian persuasion
now one might argue that labeling
someone a least
problematic fave of a certain race
is far more racist than wearing too many
buns in your hair but what do i know
rebecca fishbein over at
jezebel proved that she's one of the
good white people by
joining the pylon quoting from an
instagram commenter this is a comment
from the from the person on instagram
apparently this is a good point
black women are discriminated against
for wearing cultural hairstyles like
bantu knots and locks but white people
are not
that's not fair and that's why people
are pissed off
but isn't adele being discriminated
against right now
has any black woman ever been criticized
in publication publications across the
entire globe
for wearing her hair in a bun and even
if some black women have been
discriminated against for wearing the
hairstyle
why exactly does that mean other people
can't wear it
we're told that some people of one race
are discriminated against for wearing
something and
therefore people of another race
shouldn't wear it but
we seem to have leapfrogged over a few
of the steps in this logical progression
because there's no apparent connection
between the premise and the conclusion
and no one has ever tried to explain
what the connection would be
the problem here and the reason why the
appropriation police can never quite
explain
what appropriation is and why it's wrong
and why any of this matters
is that the whole concept is meaningless
i mean you would think that the people
who loved to see everything as fluid and
on a spectrum
and a human construct would understand
that culture is by definition the most
fluid human construct of all
culture is simply the customs traditions
arts and institutions of any group of
people
and those customs traditions arts and
institutions are always
evolving and changing and they're in
constant exchange
with other cultures in this era of
global connectivity
that process is in hyperdrive it happens
quicker
and more efficiently this is why even if
it made sense to accuse one culture of
stealing
you know a style from another culture
which it doesn't because
theft deprives the victim of the thing
being stolen
but nobody's being prevented from
wearing buns just because adele was
wearing them
you know as if there's some sort of
scarcity of buns and adele is hogging
more than her chair
um but even so you know even if it made
sense
we still couldn't identify who is
actually guilty of stealing
from whom humans have been making
culture in some form or another for tens
of thousands of years
for you know for most trends and
fashions therefore it's not possible to
identify a definitive date or place of
origin
even if you could what influenced the
person who came up with it and what
influenced the influences of that person
and so on and so on and so on
this problem was illustrated recently
when a white business owner in seattle
was forced to
issue an apology for wearing dreadlocks
which supposedly appropriated from
african culture too but
dreadlocks have been worn all throughout
history by people of all different races
and cultures and traditions
vikings wore dreadlocks hindus war still
wear dreadlocks
who owns them answer nobody
because style is not a thing that can be
owned
we might as well say that whoever first
baked a loaf of bread
now owns the concept of bread and only
the direct descendants of that person
are allowed to experience its joys which
are considerable
of course you know i'm trying to engage
with the concept of cultural
appropriation honestly and logically
which means i'm missing the point
it is not supposed to make sense it is
simply supposed to be accepted and
obeyed
it is just another means of controlling
people and sowing division and discord
in a society
that i would say already has a surplus
of both
and that is why adele's cancellers are
cancelled and everyone
who uses the phrase cultural
appropriation unironically is also
cancelled
that'll do it for today thanks for
watching have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew clavin
show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton